LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it
and why they do it.
Today, we're going
to do exactly that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi everybody, and
welcome to this episode
of "Coffee With A Googler."
Today, I'm going to be meeting
with Lauren Dale, who's
a product marketing
manager here at Google.
Word is that she's responsible
for a lot of Google I/O.
So Lauren, thanks for coming
and meeting with me today.
How are you?
LAUREN DALE: Good.
Thanks so much for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We're
so happy to have you.
You're a product marketing
manager at Google.
What does that involve?
What do you do?
LAUREN DALE: So I'm on our
Developer Marketing team, which
means that we make sure
developers know about all
of our latest and greatest
products and APIs,
how to use them and
where to find them.
A big part of that is
planning Google I/O.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So now, I hear you
are one of the VIPs responsible
for bringing the awesomeness
that is I/O to developers.
Can tell us a bit
about it this year?
LAUREN DALE: Sure.
Well, to begin, I'm
not the only VIP.
There are a lot of
people who are involved
in bringing I/O to life.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But thanks
for taking the time out
from planning to
meet with us today.
LAUREN DALE: Sure, no problem.
I/Os going to be happening again
in San Francisco at Moscone
West from May 28th
through the 29th.
Developers can expect a lot of
really inspirational sessions,
one to one time with Googlers
to ask all their burning
questions, and a lot of
interactive experiences
in our Sandbox base so they
can actually touch and feel
and play with our products.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so we
talked about the Sandbox,
and I was at Google
I/O last year,
and the Sandbox was awesome
with things like pop-up talks
and with code labs.
Can you tell us like what's
going to be in the Sandbox
this year?
LAUREN DALE: Yeah,
so the Sandbox
is actually going to
be bigger this year
than it was last year.
So it's the most
popular part of I/O,
so we want to make sure that
enough people can fit in
and we have enough
room for everyone.
So we'll have even more pop-up
talks than we had last year.
We'll have more code labs.
Code labs are very, very
popular with developers.
So, in addition
to more code labs,
we'll have more Googlers on
hand so that everyone can
get their questions answered.
We'll have even more
interactive experiences
available for developers.
So bigger, more experiences,
more space, more fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
bigger, better, more fun?
LAUREN DALE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK,
that sounds really cool,
because last year was pretty
big and pretty fun too.
Now, one of the things is that
not everybody's lucky enough
to be able to go to
I/O. There's only
a limited number of tickets,
and they're sold out already.
So what can people who
aren't able to go to I/O
and experience this
for themselves-- what
options are available for them?
LAUREN DALE: Yeah, we have
a couple different options
for people who aren't able
to make it to San Francisco.
We understand that not
everyone can travel,
and also, we have space
constraints within Moscone--
we can't fit everyone.
But for those who
can't make it, we
have one option,
which is I/O Extended.
I/O Extended events happen
throughout the world.
Some are hosted actually
at Google offices,
and others are hosted
by local developer
communities in local spaces.
Last year we had Extended
events in over 91 countries,
so chances are, there's
something happening near you.
If you're interested, you can
go to google.com/io and find
a list of the events that are
happening in your neighborhood.
If nothing is
happening near you,
then you can actually host
your own Extended event.
We have details listed on how
to actually do that, as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, I
actually was lucky enough
to go to Google I/O Extended
in Kirkland, Washington
a couple of years ago.
I have to say, it was an
amazing experience to the fact
that I sat there and
I watched the keynote
and I fell in love with
Google, and now I work here.
It worked out well for me.
Hopefully it will work
out well for Google.
Time will tell.
LAUREN DALE: I think so.
I think you're doing OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, I'm enjoying it.
So back to the conference
at South in San Francisco.
I know there's lots of really
cool, lots of innovative stuff.
You've spoken a little
bit about the Sandbox.
What kind of other fun stuff
should we expect to see?
LAUREN DALE: Yeah,
well, we're really
trying to bring
the magic of Google
here in Mountain View
to San Francisco.
So think, lots of food,
lots of fun spaces
to play and even comfy seating.
Our offices-- we have a
lot of different features
that aren't your
typical corporates.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
lovely quirkiness, right?
LAUREN DALE: Yes.
Yeah.
So we're really trying to
bring that into San Francisco
and into Moscone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah, I'm
looking forward to seeing it.
LAUREN DALE: In
terms of content--
I can't give away too much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Can
you give a little?
LAUREN DALE: No.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Aw!
LAUREN DALE: We
don't want to spoil
the magic of what will actually
happen when we're there.
But we will have a new format
for sessions, so bigger session
rooms than we've
had in years past.
So people shouldn't
have to fight for space
to actually get into a session.
LAURENCE MORONEY: There
were some long lines,
so we're trying to avoid that.
LAUREN DALE: Yeah.Yup.
Definitely trying to
avoid that this year.
We'll also more
inspirational content.
So we have a lot of really
cool speakers lined up--
some women from our
Women Techmakers team
to talk about some amazing
products that they're building.
We'll explore what's
new in Android.
That's always a big
hefty topic, and so we
expect a lot of people
to be interested in that.
Then, kind of highlighting
some new fun things we're
doing in the gaming space
and web platform space.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
I believe you brought a video
showing some of the magic
that we had last year.
LAUREN DALE: I did.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Can we roll that video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: It's
great to see all of you.
Welcome to Google I/O.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Great video.
It brings lots of
great memories,
and hopefully in
coming I/O, we're
going to be building
lots of new memories.
So what was the
website again where
people can go to find out more?
LAUREN DALE: Yes,
google.com/io is our website.
People can find out all of the
sessions and various content
aspects that we'll be having
at the event this year.
We also have a pretty
fun Chrome experiment
that developers can play
with and check out the source
code as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, yeah.
I actually played with
that Chrome experiment,
and it's a real hoot.
You can, like, stretch
rubber bands across pegs
and then play them and
play along with music.
It's a really nice
little experiment
showing HTML5 can work,
and maybe a little taste
of the kind of things developers
can learn at I/O South.
LAUREN DALE: Yeah,
and we definitely
encourage you to check
it out on your phone.
It's even more fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: [LAUGHS]
I've got to try that.
I haven't done that.
I've only done it on my laptop.
So Google I/O 2015, end of
May here in San Francisco
in the Moscone Center.
There's also going to be Google
I/O Extended events all around,
so on google.com/io, you'll
be able to find out all about
them.
So Laura, thank you so
much for coming today.
It's been a whole lot of fun.
I've learned so much
about I/O, and I'm really
looking forward to the event.
LAUREN DALE: Thanks
so much for having me.
It's been great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So everybody,
thanks for watching this far.
We've got more episodes
of "Coffee With A Googler"
on the Google
developers channel.
You can learn all about the
Google I/O on the website that
we mentioned, google.com/io.
If you've got any
questions for me
or if you've got any
questions for Lauren,
please just post them
in the comments area
beneath this window.
Check out the rest of
our videos, and also,
check out when--
if you're at I/O,
we're going to have a very
special "Coffee With A Googler"
event there.
So thanks again,
and see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]